みんなーヤンヤンつけボーというかしスペルだろうか
スーパーとかコンビニ等でもよく見ると中身例えたことありますでしょうか
こちらで結構どこでも見ると思うんですけども原付もどのようなお菓子かというと普通
にまで開けます
開けるとさあカ所に区分されておりますチョコパウダー道でて食べるかと言いますと
ほぼとってそこに来てすけってパウダーちょっとでつけて食べるとうまいでも問題が
良い案つけボーは多い県ですけどもぉおおてまち的チョコレートにつけパウダーにつき
でパックやってるとかん
美味しい
インって本当にアンフィんですけどめんどくせーのとこの困っててちょっともんたい
ないなって思って多いと思うんですけどやっぱりそんなちょっと物足りないよやん漬物
ために今回
物足りねえなら大きいものを作ればいいのように一つしかねコミュに昆布へと
世界一を聞い世界超軽量ヤンヤンつけボーを作っているところですよいやほんとに多い
と思うんですよ
連付けば小さくて物足りないそんなことを思った私
再度人はこんなもんですねこれぐらいです綺麗でヤンつけボー作ったらもう某まで会著
もたっぷりつくパウダーめちゃくちゃですけど最後の3人じゃねーかと思いましてでき
ヤンヤンつけ
送ったらそのなんか来ましたがなくなるんじゃないかと思いまして早速作っていこうと
思います
0ひょっと指で早速作っていこうと思いますまずはちょっとベースになるチョコを作っ
ていきたいと思うんですけどもね駄目かその防砂して連れて取れる柔らかいチョコを
作るのは難しいということであの僕すごい平気な顔してるんですけども実はこの部屋
強風の暖房30度でございますありがとうございますこんなとしていますがじつは死に
そうです
ra くださいぱど4波で bl しました
なーんーちょっと見にくいですね
ヘアどんだけではなかなかチョコが溶けないので
ドライヤーかけていきましょう
水守れ
par
ear
wh
はいという意味でだいぶ溶けてきました
これ実際アーティストグラムで少ないって見えると思うんですけど実は
や慰安つけばのチョコって結構あのカップに対する少ないんですよ
カップのここらへんしかチョコないんで結構いいバレーだと思います
対するでパウダーのを作っていきましょうこの入ってる部分がなんか三角コーナー
っぽいんで実際の三角コーナーを使っていきますなぜ下がっ
できましたここにパウダーをたくさんが出てきます
[拍手]
はい結構たくさん入ったと思います
さあ
[拍手]
はいというわけで無事に完成しましたまあ巨大すぎるがゆえのネックポイントもあり
ますがそこは近接見ていきましょう
まあチョコがここに溜まってるんですけどここに来て棒を入れてすくってこんな
ポンチョでつけてパクってくれる感じですちょちょっと硬いんね食べたいわ
チョコを溶かしておいてくれると
袖もためあていとーございま問題の棒の部分なんですけど
それさん一家石塚でしょヤンヤンつけボーが変わりの巨種を探した時に投げのみ使わ
なくてもうこれしかないと思って何資産を準備しました
事いいされツアーのピーっちょっとでかくネットで書いた
まぁこんなこともあろうがたくさんフランスパンを準備しておいた
それゆえイヤー君ゼンダ城米8月6オーバー
キャンペーン
というわけでさっそく食べてみましょう大事なのは
アズです本当にチョコがさんのつかどうかですよね
aname
おーすげー全然月ますでこれを俺をここに肌たくさんつけると
ハッハー完全に44付骨8話タグ食べてみようと思います
これ世界一大きい
4重要だ
いただけます
いただきます
[音楽]
wh
me
car
美味しいんですよそれはジャイアンツってボードもう片方から多分フランスパンにして
正解なんですよねあと
とても一人では
食べません誰かー
[音楽]